an intense manhunt in France has turned
up no sign of the gunman who killed at
least two people and what's being called
a terror attack a third victim is
brain-dead the shooter opened fire near
a Christmas market in the city of
Strasbourg last night police named a 29
year old suspect who has been flagged
for extremist ties they say they tried
to arrest him before the attack France
has raised its terror alert status to
the highest level Roxana Saberi is in
Strasbourg where police say the suspect
may have fled to nearby Germany Roxana
good morning good morning a top French
counterterrorism official says witnesses
heard the gunman yell Allahu Akbar our
God is great when he opened fire here at
the Christmas market last night and the
mayor of Strasbourg says it was a terror
attack the streets here are much quieter
today as the search for the suspect
continues streets covered with Christmas
lights were filled with screams as the
lone gunman sprayed shots near a
Christmas market people caught in the
chaos ran for cover
like Eason Farris heard several shots
and I thought maybe it's firecrackers he
said but then I saw a lot of people
running scared crying kids and all so I
ran away and hid in a restaurant police
have named the shooter as Strasbourg
born Sharif Shawkat according to a US
law enforcement official shakatdas
believed to have had an automatic rifle
and a knife he was known to French
authorities previously convicted of
assault and theft and spent time in jail
he's also on a terror watch list for
possible extremist ties police raided
his apartment on the morning of the
attack on unrelated charges but he
wasn't there after the shooting at the
market police chased the gunman through
the streets exchanging fire he was
injured but got away this morning more
than 350 security forces are searching
for the man who added the self-promoted
capital of Christmas to the list of
cities hit by terror
police have detained several people for
questioning no terror group has claimed
responsibility for the attack so far
Roxana thank you